other news here at six it's been the
talk of the strip for several months now
the future of fountain blue on the north
end of the strip tonight that project is
back on again joe mohler joining us now
live from the property with one we might
see some progress on that site
joe we all know this building it's been
empty for years and it's right across
the street from circus circus here's a
live look this evening it was originally
supposed to be the fountain blue las
vegas it then switched owners but now
developers say it will be the fountain
blue las vegas opening in 20-23
it's a great building it was always a
great building the giant blue building
towering over the north end of the strip
is getting some much needed attention
this has
come full circle back to us and we're
very honored and excited about it
developers are bringing back the
original plan for the building that was
born more than a decade ago the resort
fountain blue las vegas it's a fully
integrated resort we of course hit on 25
acres an 8 acre pool deck about 37 a
little over 3 700 rooms belton blue
development president brett mavson says
they plan to open the resort in late
2023 he says the partnership with coke
investments will help get this job done
if it wasn't for our
partnership and the uniqueness and the
fact that we have it's a very simple
partnership it's not a complex capital
structure
it just gives us the opportunity to
see this for to fruition richardson
construction which helped build nearby
resorts world was brought in for the
project governor steve syslock is
excited about getting this finished
we're talking over 3 000 construction
jobs on this site right now they're
going to be working in 6 000 permanent
jobs that we desperately need which is
helping to bring the economy back
muffson says this resort will bring a
touch of luxury not seen elsewhere in
the city las vegas is the perfect
perfect city for our brand
now back out here live the developers
say you can expect a large casino pools
and plenty of entertainment here at the
resort they expect it to open in the
fourth quarter of 2023. reporting live
on the strip this evening joe mohler
live local now